la suite de ce 78 à présent avec la
chronique environnement bonsoir Sophie
bonsoir on va parler de biodynamie oui
AB biodynamie kzako alors un indice on
dit aussi agriculture biodynamique acoup
ça vous aide pas beaucoup je vouis vous
aider encore un petit peu plus c'est un
des courants fondateurs de l'agriculture
biologique qui est né en
1924 en Allemagne une école qui se veut
une alternative à l'agriculture
contemporaine qui est intensive et qui
rejette donc en bloc les avancées
techniques et industrielles au contraire
les méthodes utilisé sont plutôt
naturelles et elles prennent en compte
les cycles lunaires ou les
constellations on en verra un exemple
sur le plateau des préparations naturel
qui sont utilisés mais avant toute chose
on a posé la question aux cquantinoisà
pour savoir si eux même sont mieux
renseigné que moi savait mieux ce que
c'était la biodynamique en
image non l'agriculture bio à la rigueur
mais biodynamique non ça me dit rien il
y a le le préfixe bio donc j'imagine que
c'est biologique et dynamique je vois
pas ce que ça peut apporter derrière
benah quelque chose des produits bio
mais dynamique je sais pas c'est rapport
avec la
biologie dynamique c'est peut-être pour
que ce soit plus développé que ce ne l'
actuellement biodynamique c'est le
mouvement dans la dans le bio non je
connais l'agriculture bio logique mais
pas biodynamique donc la différence le
dynamisme ça veut dire
que c'est plus ça ça bouge plus enfin
dynamique c'est une idée de mouvement
donc je me pose la
question et la question se pose et on va
voir la réponse le concept est un petit
peu obscur pour la plupart d'entre nous
donc pour en parler sur le plateau nous
avons Alonso Jimenez bonsoir vous vous
êtes le membre éelinois de de
l'agriculture biodynamique qui est un
mouvement en France euh et puis nous
avons aussi Ilse h Schlager vous vous
êtes la présidente des associations
démarrer c'est mieux d'accord plus
facile à dire présidente des Amis des
jardins croissillon et vous cultivez
vous plantez dans ce jardin avec tous
les membres de l'association en
biodynamie donc la première question
qu'on a envie de vous poser évidemment
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est simplement
concrètement Alonzo alors la la la
culture biodynamique utilise des
préparations donc on vous montrera les
préparations après et le principe c'est
quoi c'est on fait attention à la terre
plus que dans la biologique oui tout à
fait et donc il a une préparation
vraiment spécifique qui est donc la la
500 la la corne de bouse que l'on
utilise mais globalement le concept ça
veut dire quoi biodynamique biodynamique
c'est-à-dire soigner vraiment la terre
pour soigner l'homme puisque c'est
vraiment ce que la Terre va donner qui
va permettre à l'homme de pouvoir donc
il y a plus d'osmose entre la planète la
Terre l'environnement et et l'homme en
fait oui plus d'osmose plus de vitalité
le C voilà et le ciel donc ça veut dire
que on considère que le ciel a une
influence sur l'agriculture ah ben bien
sûr on voit bien qu'on il PL pas comm
maintenant on est on est malheureux hein
on il a trop de soleil on est malheureux
aussi un peu plus de soleil en ce moment
et encore c'est plus fin il y a encore
les
constellations des planètes qui qui
circulent là-dedans alors exactement
donc vous utilisez notamment un
agenda qui vous permet de de choisir les
moments où où il vaut mieux planter
certaines certains produits plutôt que
d'autres on va le voir qui va arriver à
l'écran ça veut dire que par exemple là
nous sommes au mois de mai est-ce que
vous pouvez m'aider à décrypter un petit
peu cette cet agenda là oh là il va
falloir des lunettes bon on voit il y a
différentes périodes différentes
couleurs ça veut dire quoi ces couleurs
les couleurs ça veut dire que il y a des
jours qui sont en rouge par exemple ce
sont c'est c'est voilà c'est plus
chaleur donc fruits donc tous les
légumes dire qu'il vaut mieux planter
des fruits il vaut mieux planter des
fruits au début du mois planter semer
récolter on traite on traite l'arbre on
traite les arbres à fruit à ce momentl
d'cord et là je vois le 14 donc on est
dans une période fleur si je me trompe
pas parce qu'on est en vert voilà c'est
encore plus facile comme ça c'estc grand
j'espère que vous avez des grandes télé
chez vous alors bon alors concrètement
tout ça quel impact ça peut avoir sur
les fruits et les légumes est-ce que
c'est plus ils sont plus gros plus
vitaminés qu'est-ce qu'ils ont plus goût
plus de goût plus de goût et plus ferme
ouais plus de qualité au niveau de la
pousse aussi si on respecte ça par
exemple une plante qu'on va une fleur
qu'on va récolter un jour fleur elle va
garder ses propriétés plus longtemps
donc si on veut faire des tisanes par
exemple avec on va avoir une plante qui
va avoir plus ses propriétés qui va mux
garder ses
propriétés oui pour les légumes c'est
pareil hein il faut savoir à quel moment
on les coille parce que parce qu'on on
peut toujours les manger mais respecter
leur cycle aussi quelque part ça a
quelque chose d'un petit peu magique
peut-être d'irrationnel au premier
abordou c'est de la magie c'est quoi de
la biodynamie ben non c'est des
préparations c'est la mag c'est magique
quand même pour le calendrier on utilise
des données astronomiques hein ce sont
les places des constellations et des
planètes qui vont aussi même si ça nous
paraît extrêmement loin elles vont avoir
une répercussion une influence sur les
plantes ouis vraiment on peut dire il y
a des périodes qui ont une influence sur
la terre exactement toutes les périodes
leur influence est-ce qu'on peut selon
le le comment le ciel se présente par
exemple là on est globalement dans une
période qui est plus propice à quoi
alors d'après au pour aujourd'hui pour
pour tout ce qui est fleurs donc pour
travailler donc cette période là il y a
aussi des périodes défavorable qui où il
y a des occultations où il y a des
phénomènes dans le ciel qui perturbent
la terre donc on évite de de toucher la
terre pendant C ces momentsl oui on peut
dire que si c'est si on on on utilise
actuellement quand ces fleurs et on met
des des légumes ben ils vont pousser
tout de suite enfin ils vont essayer de
d'aller vers vers la la fleurison alors
il y a certaines personnes qui ont
étudié de façon un peu plus scientifique
ces ces ces choses-là il y a notamment
Maria Tun c'est ça oui tout à fait oui
donc qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait de quoi
elle s'est rendu compte finalement elle
a fait des tas d'essais en plein champ
où elle a pu déterminer en parallèle si
je fais à tel jour et à tel jour
qu'est-ce que j'ai comme résultat et
donc elle a pu avec ce protoc là
déterminer effectivement tout ce ce
calendrier qui permet de de de voir que
telle planète a telle influence et elle
a vraiment systématiser ce c'est pas
facile pour un agriculteur de respecter
véritablement toutes ces données mais
s'il le fait au mieux les résultats
vraiment sont sentir pour la production
et surtout pour la qualité de ce qu' va
produire et puis il y a pas que ça il y
a aussi donc des préparations un peu
particulières là vous nous avez apporter
sur le plateau des ingrédients qu'on va
peut-être pouvoir utiliser vous pouvez
me décrire ce que que vous avez amené
alors dans la préparation il y a deux
préparations de base il y a la 500 donc
c'est le c'est la Bousse de corne la
Bousse de corne qu'est-ce que c'est
alors c'est de la Bousse de vache
làdedans que l'on a mis dans une corne
de vache l'iver on met la Bousse de
vache dans cette corne et on l'enterre
onenterre on s'en occupe pas au
printemps la ressort on a la préparation
alors cette préparation qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait alors cette préparation qui il
faut je vous montre cette préparation
cette Bousse de vache s'est transformée
en terre qui n'a pas d'odeur donc elle a
vraiment été
transformé sous la terre et avec les les
formes bien précises de de la corordne
qui ont concentré les forces elle s'est
transformé en cette cette espèce de de
terre ouis donc cette terre là on va la
mettre dans un récipient comme celui-là
dans une grande jar à peu près avec elle
doit être plus en hauteur parce qu'on a
du mal VO pour les besoins du plateau on
n pas pris une J entière et on va la
dynamiser selon le principe que il se va
vous montrer oui alors comment on
dynamise il y a une façon
spécifique parce que sinon ça é bous
tout de suite tout à fait tout à fait
dans cette façon on va créer un vortex
en tournant un tourbillon tourbillon il
faut aller au-dessus pour le voir donc
là il y a pas beaucoup de place donc
effectivement on
tourne tout de suite le de retour on
fait
la ensuite on voilà on casse le vortex
et on tourne dans l'utre sens et donc
c'est cette alterne on alterne vraiment
l'essence pendant une heure pendant une
heure pant une heure vous continuez ce
mouvement exactement il faut se relayer
c'est ça qui faut se relayer ou on peut
se relayer mais voilà exactement
exactement et à quoi ça sert alors ça ça
dynamise et ça potentialise la
préparation donc dynamiser ça veut dire
que sur la plante que c'estàdire que
l'eau a vraiment pris toutes les qualité
de cette terre transformée déjà ce qui
fait que avec très peu de de de de
quantité bon pour la 500 la 500 elle va
favoriser la le système racinaire qui va
faire que la plante qui va se développer
va être plus plus plus plus fort plus
résistance au malance d'accord donc ça
va en même temps nourrir le sol nourrir
la plante ce qui fait que on n pas
besoin arrêtez-vous on va pas vous
obliger à
tourner aller comme ça mais bon et puis
il y a pas que ça il y a aussi ce qu'on
appelle le silice de corne nous on a
recueilli le témoignage hier lors de
votre de votre réunion d'association
d'une professionnelle qui a fait ça
l'été dernier c'est un peu pour les plus
courageux parce qu'il faut se lever tout
le matin je vous propose de voir ça en
image ben c'est super agréable en fait
donc pendant 1 heure on va dynamiser
cette préparation dans un pot en gris
avec de l'eau de pluie et cetera et
c'est une seule personne qui doit le
faire voilà donc pendant une heure j'ai
fait ça et et c'est extrêmement agréable
c'est pas du tout contraignant ça passe
à une vitesse parce que c'est vrai que
j'avais quand même des a priori hein je
me suis dit mais je vais avoir mal au
bras j'ai en plus je fume donc je me
suis préparé des cigarettes en disant ça
va être l'enfer je je et en fait pas du
tout parce que on pense à plein de
choses on regarde l'eau qui tourne on
écoute les oiseaux on voit le soleil qui
se lève enfin tout d'un coup on est pris
dans quelque chose justement qu'on prend
pas le temps de voir si on fait pas ça
si on fait pas ça on le voit pas on dort
on prend son café on regarde ordi on
regarde ses mails parce que je fais
comme tout le monde enfin je veux dire
je suis pas pas particulièrement zen
bouddhiste tout ça quoi alors il se vous
êtes donc on aussi la traductrice du
livre qui fait référence de rudolp
Steiner qui est donc l'inventeur de la
biodynamie comment la trè qui fait la
vous êtes la troisème traductrice et
maintenant et les gens veulent plus que
ça depuis qu'ils l'ont vu d'accord ça
c'est c'est vraiment tous les précepts
c'est vre traduction est meilleure
ouais parce que je suis non ben ceux qui
ont fait avant c'était des des gens très
instruits mais ils savaient pas le conna
pas de rapport avec la terre quoi alors
Rudolf Steiner euh c'est aussi lui qui a
inventé le principe de la pédagogie
Steiner mais là c'est vraiment un cours
pour les agriculteurs pour dire c'est
faisable quand on est un professionnel à
grande échelle on peut faire de la
biodynamie c'est ça oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr ils étaient tous à grande
échelle à ceux qui sont venus ouais
à lui parce qu' il voyait plus comment
faire ouais avec par rapport au à la à
la nouvelle mode de faire l'agriculture
avec des produits chimiques donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
agriculteur qui utilise cette méthode à
grande échelle si alors qui utilise
aujourd'hui c'est utilisé quand même
cette agriculture faut être équipé pour
pour ces surfaces quoi alors Alonzo vous
vous me disiez les viticulteurs
utilisent cette méthode oui les
viticulteurs dans les grands domaines
certains grand domaines utilisent ise et
tous les vins qui sont sous le label
desm utilisent
aussi ces préparations qui changent
véritablement et qui sont vraiment très
très appréciés faut dire aussi qu'ils
veulent pas mettre ça dessus parce que
ça ça ça nuirait à leur propre publicité
ou il y a une mauvaise image la
biodynamie parce que non non pas du tout
non non non enfin peut-être que certains
pensent que c'est c'est quoi c'est le
fait d'avoir le label bous de corne ou
voilà c'est ça peut-être qui pose
problème procéd paraissent pe
scientifique donc effectivement pe être
mais il y a un exemple à à skem en
Égypte où il y a plus de 700 fermes qui
travaillent en biodynamie euh
l'expérience a 34 ans donc ça se fait à
très très grande échelle il y a plus de
3000 2500 3000 paysans qui travaillent
donc ils ont pu développer euh tout un
système de plantes en agroalimentaire en
médecine en produits cosmétiques pour
euh pour pour alors les écoles euh il y
en a euh en Allemagne il y en a euh il y
a un petit peu des des gens qui osent
dire qu'ils le font en Angleterre aussi
en France on peut se former à la dynami
oui comment on fait oui mais attends
parce que se la seule la seule école
vraiment qui était une école elle a dû
fermer parce que le mais cette école
marque surtout que l'on a que qui est le
centre de formation pour le pour la
biodynamie il a des la solution c'est de
venir vous voir voilà vous allez
expliquer vous ferez la démonstration et
vous expliqu com pr vous à vous montrer
tout ce que l'on fait comme on le fait
merci à vous merci Sophie vousou Luz
apporter une précision vous a coupé dans
votrean pour finir donc c'est le label
démire qui appuie tous les produits qui
sontam voilà exaement cette
AGC que l'on trouve dans les magasins
biologiques ou class on en trouve
surtout biologique en Allemagne a
beaucoup ici un peu moins parce que bon
voilà je vous remercie merci donc nous
avoir présenté cette méthode de
biodynamique